KOBI MAGNEZI: Hello, and thank
you for joining us today.
My name is Kobi Magnezi.
I'm product manager for GKE.
And I have the pleasure
to have here with me today
Donovan Carter, senior
devops engineer at Dexcom.
DONOVAN CARTER: Thanks, Kobi.
It's a pleasure to be here.
As Kobi said, my
name's Donovan Carter.
I'm a senior devops
engineer with Dexcom.
I've been working with
Dexcom and the devops team
on our platform team for
the last three years,
and it's been a joy and an
honor to get to know Kobi
through our mutual love and
interest of Google Kubernetes
Engine, which we're here
to talk to you today about.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Awesome.
So we are here to
share with you some
of the best practices
that you can follow
to achieve high availability and
business continuity with GKE.
But first, let's define what
business continuity means.
Business continuity means having
a proper plan, preparation,
and mitigation
strategy in place so,
in case something happens
with the potential
to disrupt your business,
your organization
will have the ability to sustain
its critical application.
We'll break this discussion
to two parts, day zero
and day two.
And for each one, we'll provide
some key recommendation.
DONOVAN CARTER:
And my [INAUDIBLE]
on this is to discuss how
Dexcom leverages this business
continuity approach.
For those of you who
may not be aware,
Dexcom is a industry leader
in the continuous glucose
monitoring space.
What that means is for
people with type 1 diabetes,
we give them a
platform of services
that they can use to both keep
in touch with their own disease
or the disease of
a loved one as far
as monitoring levels of
their actual blood glucose.
Because of that, we have
chosen Kubernetes and Google
Kubernetes Engine specifically
because with the needs
of our customers
being what they are,
we have to provide
that service to them
in a highly available way.
And so the obvious choice was
to go with Google Kubernetes
Engine.
KOBI MAGNEZI: So can
you share more, Donovan,
why you decided to use a
managed service instead
of using your own Kubernetes and
install it on your environment?
DONOVAN CARTER: Absolutely.
It comes from experience.
We were using another cloud
provider prior to our migration
to Google a few years ago.
And on that cloud provider,
we had made the decision
to essentially deploy
our own Kubernetes
service within the cloud.
What we found out is that
it's really hard to do that.
It requires a lot of
operations, and we're
going to get into that today.
And we decided not to
invest some of that toil,
the monitoring, the alerting,
all of the things that
go into running
your own Kubernetes,
which you can do because
Google presented itself
as not only an industry
leader and a contributor
to the Kubernetes project,
but also provides it
as a managed service,
which to us--
I mean, the things that we have
to deal with on a day-to-day
was very, very attractive.
And so far, we've been really,
really excited about that.
The other added bonus
is that it scales.
It scales ridiculously well, and
we don't have to do anything.
We don't really have
to think about it.
It's been a life-changer
for us to go
from where we were several
years ago to where we are now.
And it's exciting
to see where we're
going to go in the future.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Awesome.
So let's look at
several recommendation
we have for day zero.
And when thinking about high
availability of GKE cluster,
it is important
to carefully plan
the topology and configuration
of your GKE cluster
before you even
deploy your workloads.
Let's look quickly on
the GKE architecture
and main components.
When you provision a
new Kubernetes cluster,
GKE provisions the
machine, the underlying GCE
resources that are
required for the control
plane and the nodes.
We also manage the rollout
of the Kubernetes version
and patches, and their
availability in the GKE fleet.
GKE manages the control
plane, including
all the components running on
it, things like API server,
[INAUDIBLE], and others.
We also manage the software
that runs on the node.
That includes operating system
image, kubelet, and others.
When you create a
cluster, you can
decide on the right
topology for your business.
You can choose to create a zonal
cluster, which includes one
replica of your control plane.
And then you can
decide whether you
want to have all your
nodes spanned across three
different zones or
whether you want
to keep them all in one
zone with the control plane.
That really depends on your
needs from the environment.
The alternative is to create a
regional cluster, for which GKE
provisions three machines
for the control plane.
And the node pools are
also spanned across three
availability zones.
The control plane
redundancy provide
a high-availability
control plane,
which, in turn, offer higher
SLA for the Kubernetes API.
Even though your
business application,
those that run on the nodes,
will continue to run and serve
traffic when the
control plane is
down temporarily, for
example, for maintenance,
it is recommended to
use regional cluster
for highly available workloads.
Kubernetes control plane is
responsible to observe, scale,
and repair your cluster.
And when higher
availability is required,
regional clusters
should be preferred.
Whichever topology
you end up using,
GKE offer a fully
managed experience
for the control plane.
That means that we
take care of backups,
repairing the control
plane if something happen.
We make sure it's available
through monitoring,
health checks, and auto-repair.
We also keep you up to date, and
we upgrade your control planes
to the latest Kubernetes
version and security patch
available in a reliable manner.
And most importantly,
you get Google SRE
to monitor and manage your
infrastructure for you.
Nodes are a shared
responsibility.
That means that while the
control plane is hosted
in a Google project, the
nodes are run in your project,
in the customer project.
That being said, GKE offers
a variety of capabilities
that automate the lifecycle
management of the nodes
as well, and we'll
cover those next.
So now that you decided
on the cluster topology,
it is important to consider
the scaling strategy.
While scalability is
important for continuity,
scaling is necessary to
ensure that as you grow,
we match your needs.
So we can grow the number
of pods, the number of nodes
based on demand.
GKE includes several
auto-scaling capabilities
that allow GKE to automatically
resize your cluster based
on your configuration and
some monitored signals.
Donovan, I would love
to hear how Dexcom
is using auto-scaling as well.
DONOVAN CARTER: Absolutely.
Dexcom's grown tremendously,
and being a part of it
has been an awesome experience.
But part of that comes
with design and planning
and specifically having
to scale up resources.
And being a part of a cloud
provider such as Google really,
really helps with that.
Things that we don't have
to think about things thanks
to the GKE cluster
auto-scalar are,
do we have enough nodes
for our workloads?
Thanks for the GKE
cluster auto-scalar,
that problem is solved.
It brings in new nodes
whenever we need them.
Additionally, we've been able
to leverage horizontal pod
auto-scaling in concert
with the cluster auto-scalar
to provide a better quality
of service to our customers
during peak utilization hours.
Being a worldwide company, that
can be at any time of the day
depending on what
region we're looking at.
So having to have a
person monitor that
and manually intervene
just doesn't make sense.
We've also seen the opposite.
When we're at our valley
utilization period,
we're able to save money as
well as resources for Google
by scaling down to an
acceptable threshold
to provide the same
quality of service
and not use those resources,
which has been wonderful.
KOBI MAGNEZI: And
auto-scaling really
help you with scaling up and
down to meet your demand,
but sometimes we do need to
do some capacity planning,
especially when you
expect some peak demand
seasons like Black Friday,
Cyber Monday, or New Year.
In this period of
time, we may want
to reserve GCE
capacity so that when
we need that capacity--
for example, for scaling,
repairing, or
upgrading-- we'll have
a reserved pool of resources
available for the cluster
to consume.
Basically, GKE reservation
is an integration between GKE
and GCE zonal reservation.
So you can create a specific
or non-specific reservation,
and GKE will create
new resources based
on the pool reserved for you.
There's an example
here on the right side
where we create reservation
of three machines,
we verify the
reservation, and then
we create a cluster to consume
any matching reservation
that we created.
Now that we covered the
provisioning and scaling
of nodes, let's talk about
the application, your business
application, those that
run on the nodes, different
application and defined
behavior and needs.
Some applications are stateless,
and some are stateful.
More than 50% of GKE customers
run stateful workloads
on Kubernetes successfully.
It's not an easy task, but
luckily, Kubernetes and GKE
offer configuration
and tools to support
different type of application.
Donovan, do you guys run any
stateful application on GKE?
DONOVAN CARTER: We do.
And when you say it's not
easy, you're absolutely right.
There are certainly things
that make it difficult or less
difficult, and I think we're
going to get into those here
in just a second.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Exactly.
And when you run different
types of application,
you also need to
think about disruption
and how you can
tolerate disruption.
Pod Disruption
Budget, or PDB, allows
you to state your
disruption tolerance.
In other words, if your
application is, let's say,
replicated, you can
specify how many
replicas you are
willing to sacrifice
when voluntary events,
like upgrade, happens.
In this example on
the right side here,
we specify that we cannot
tolerate less than two replicas
of our application.
This is just another way
to say max unavailable
equal 1 if you have three
replicas and you want only one
to be unavailable.
GKE respects PDB
up to 60 minutes
and also termination grace
period up to 60 minutes.
So that's two hours in total.
As I mentioned, PDB
covers voluntary events
like upgrades or repair.
As you can imagine,
if there is a failure
of the physical
machine, for example,
PDB clearly won't be
able to mitigate that.
The other thing
you want Kubernetes
to know about your
workloads is whether you
would benefit from
colocating some of your pods
on the same machine.
Or maybe, actually,
if you do so,
if you do colocate some of
the pods on the same machine,
you're run into risk.
Kubernetes Scheduler
automatically spread your pods
across nodes.
However, sometimes--
for example,
let's take a
stateful application
like Redis or Zookeeper.
A quorum of servers is required
to successfully commit mutation
to data.
By default,
Kubernetes may decide
to colocate pods in stateful
set on the same pod.
However, for
business continuity,
we want to make sure
that colocated pods don't
present the risk of single
point of failure, right?
So if we have stateful set,
we can use pod anti-affinity,
for example, to make sure that
Kubernetes don't schedule more
replicas on the same machine.
So each replica gets
its own machine.
On the flip side,
some application
may benefit from
actually being colocated.
For example, let's say you
have a web server and a cache
service.
You want them to be on the
same machine for better
performance and low latency.
Donovan, are you guys using any
pod anti-affinity or affinity
with your application?
DONOVAN CARTER: Yeah, it's
exactly like you said, Kobi.
We want to make sure our
sensitive workloads aren't
exposed to single points
of failure, stateful sets
specifically.
But also, we use
preemptible nodes.
And as you know,
preemptible nodes only last
for a max of 24 hours.
So we want to make sure that our
highly available workloads are
truly highly available and
not subject to single points
of failure.
And free bonus content,
preemptible nodes
are a great way to find out
if your workload is really
susceptible to that or not.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Right.
And before we move
to cover day two,
there is one more important
aspect of business continuity,
and it's about having accurate
signals so Kubernetes know
exactly how your
workload should behave,
and it can accurately monitor
the health and the state
of your workloads.
The first one is
readiness probes.
If your application,
for example,
takes some time to
start, to initiate,
you don't want
Kubernetes to start
sending customer
traffic to that workload
until it's fully ready
to serve traffic.
You do so by setting
up the readiness probe.
The other important
signal is liveness.
Is your workflow
healthy and live,
or does it require a repair?
Setting this probe can provide
better signal to Kubernetes
and also avoid false positive
cases in which Kubernetes will
try to repair unnecessarily.
So now that we set
up the cluster,
let's cover several
recommendation for day two.
So one of the most
important thing
you need to carefully
plan for day two
is your upgrade strategy--
and specifically,
a plan to continuously
upgrade your cluster.
That's because Kubernetes
minor version is released
roughly every three
months from open source,
and a patch version may
be released every month.
Because Kubernetes run
on both the control plane
and the nodes, there
are basically two places
to manage when it comes
to managing versions.
And there are many
reasons why it's
crucial to keep your
cluster up to date.
Among others is support, right?
Supported versions get regular
updates and security patches.
And we oftentime share
[INAUDIBLE] fixes from one
supported version to another.
Kubernetes release a new minor
version every three months,
and it supports up to
two minor version back.
That translates to roughly
supporting each minor version
for about nine months.
One important thing
to call out is
that an open source announced
that with Kubernetes 1.19, 1.19
will be the first release
to officially receive
a year of patch support--
so effectively prolonging
the support period
from nine months to 12 months
for Kubernetes minor version.
The other requirement
is to maintain
supported version skew
between your control
plane and the nodes.
Nodes cannot run newer version
than the control plane,
and they have to be within two
minor version from the control
plane.
So for example, if your
control plane runs on 1.19,
your node pools can run 1.19,
1.18, or 1.17, the currently
supported versions.
Since GKE automatically upgrade
the control plane in the fleet,
it is recommended to use
auto-upgrade or at least
have a plan to manually upgrade
nodes on a regular basis.
This way, you'll avoid getting
into an unsupported version
skew situation with the
upgraded control plane.
If you do decide to manage
your own upgrade workflow,
you also want to make sure that
your upgrade strategy support
any compliance that your
workload may be subject to.
There are different compliance--
PCI DSS, SOC2, and HIPAA--
that Dexcom is following as
a medical devices company.
Each one of these
compliance has actually
specific section that speaks
about how fast you should
consume critical patches.
So you definitely want to take
a look into these compliance
and make sure that your operate
strategy follow the compliance.
In GKE, we offer fully
automated process
to operate both control
plane and nodes.
Control planes are
managed by Google,
and we initiate their upgrade
as part of our GKE release.
Your business application, the
workloads running on the nodes,
stay up and running when we
upgrade the control plane.
And during the
control plane upgrade,
you are unable to change
the cluster configuration
for several minutes because we
are taking the control plane
down while bringing a new one.
So when we upgrade
zonal control plane,
we do it by creating
a new control
plane with the new version.
Then we move the network
and the disk over
and delete the
old control plane.
Regional control planes are
upgraded in a similar fashion,
but you get the redundancies
of three control planes.
So you always have two
control planes available
when we upgrade one at a time.
Node upgrade can be
automated as well,
and we strongly
recommend you to use
auto-upgrade to ensure
that your nodes are always
upgraded to match your
control plane version.
That approach, syncing
your control plane
version and your
node pool version,
not only keeping your node
infrastructure up to date,
but it also mitigate
the risk of version skew
that we discussed earlier.
By now, you may
be wondering, why
wouldn't I use auto-upgrade?
It is indeed the recommendation.
And while the
benefits are clear,
you want to ensure
business continuity also
during times of maintenance.
Node upgrades used to follow
the workflow of delete
and then create.
That means that when we
do upgrade node pools,
we delete one of the
nodes from the node pool
and then we bring a new
one with the new version.
We changed that workflow
recently with surge upgrade.
With surge upgrade, we
create and then we delete.
In other words, we bring a
new node with the new version.
And only when that
node is ready,
then we gracefully
drain the old node.
You can actually control how
many nodes can be additionally
created for surge, and
also how many existing
nodes you are
willing to sacrifice
for the upgrade process.
The combination of
MaxSurge and MaxUnavailable
also allow you to control
the pace of the upgrade.
And it actually allows you to
accelerate node upgrade, which
can be important especially
if you have large cluster.
Donovan, I know that you guys
also have very large clusters
and you are using surge upgrade
to benefit for more efficiency.
DONOVAN CARTER: That's
absolutely right, Kobi.
And it's like you said.
We see a great increase in
the continuity of the services
because they have a place to
go when that node gets taken
away as opposed to having no
place to go when the node gets
taken away.
And also, it allows us to
do our upgrades faster.
We can bring more nodes online
and remove nodes as we need to,
which greatly reduces--
I mean, you think about all
the places around the world
that companies have
to be these days.
Dexcom is no different.
We certainly have
seen great benefits
in terms of the
amount of time it
takes to execute a
node pool upgrade
thanks to surge upgrade.
It's great.
KOBI MAGNEZI: And we spoke
about the importance of upgrades
to ensure business
continuity in day two
and also the potential
disruption that these upgrades
may bring to running cluster.
Knowing that different
customers have different version
management needs, we introduced
release channels in GKE
with the objective
to actually simplify
the process of choosing
your upgrade path,
and also to allow you to
control the type of upgrades
that you need for your cluster.
Think about it this way.
Some customers may want to use
the latest Kubernetes version
because they have some
dependencies on newer
API or capability,
or because they
have some specific
business objectives.
Other customers may prefer
stability over everything
else, over functionality and
the freshness of a version.
With release channels--
and there are three release
channels, Rapid,
Regular, and Stable--
you can choose where you want
to be in terms of upgrade path.
So instead of choosing
a specific version,
you can subscribe your cluster
to a release channel that
meets your need, and GKE will
take care of the upgrade.
The differences between channels
are soak time and maturity
of the release.
So we first introduce a
version to the Rapid channel.
We let it soak.
We promote it to Regular.
We let it soak again.
And then eventually, we
promote it to Stable.
Donovan, are you using
release channels or the Rapid
or the Stable channels in
your production environment?
DONOVAN CARTER: I can't
go into specifics on that,
but I can tell you that
release channels have greatly
simplified how we evaluate
the upgrade process.
Historically, we would have
to pick and choose and study
release notes religiously.
And now, we get a
recommendation from Google
saying this has had this
amount of soak time,
and we've looked
at it and believe
it's the right version
for the workloads
that you're looking at.
So for us, we have some
sensitive workloads.
We want to make sure that
they're using the Stable
release channel.
For other workloads
or other environments,
maybe we use different
release channels
that are maybe more aggressive
or have newer features
so that we can do that earlier
in our development cycle.
KOBI MAGNEZI: And it
is important to mention
that you can unsubscribe a
cluster from release channel
if you need to do that.
And you can also migrate between
release channels in some cases.
So this all sound great.
You can automate the process.
You can configure the
nature of the upgrade
and control the
version maturity.
However, Kubernetes upgrade
can introduce breaking changes,
and they need to be
tested and validated
in a preproduction
environment so that you
can ensure business continuity.
This is why we are
introducing available versions
for channels.
Each channel will include
one default version
and available versions.
When a version becomes
default, auto-upgrade
triggers the rollout server to
promote the default versions
and upgrade the control plane
first and then your node pools
if you are using auto-upgrade.
Before a version
become default, GKE
will make it available
in the fleet.
Patch versions will be available
one week before rollout.
And minor version, which tend
to be a little bit more riskier,
will be made available
four weeks before rollout.
We recommend testing
available versions
on preproduction environment
to mitigate business continuity
risks and also to
ensure that when
we do upgrade your
production environment,
auto-upgrade can be
completed successfully.
You can use the
command line that I
have in the bottom
of this slide to view
the default and available
versions for the release
channel that you are
using for your cluster.
And sometimes, disruption simply
cannot be tolerated, right?
I mean, there are some
peak business seasons
or major company
events like trade fair.
We recommend to set up exclusion
window for these events.
With exclusion window,
you can specify
a range of dates in which you
want us to completely refrain
from any maintenance.
You can also set up
maintenance windows
to say when you do prefer
maintenance to happen.
That can help you
not only improve
predictability of the upgrade,
but it can be very handy.
Especially now when
people work from home,
you might want to ensure team
availability in alignment
with the working schedule
when maintenance actually
takes place.
Dexcom also have, I assume,
major holidays and planned
peak business hours.
How do you use maintenance
and exclusion windows?
DONOVAN CARTER:
Yeah, it's funny you
mention working from home and
the nature of the situation
that we all find ourselves
in because in the olden days,
we'd want to see people in
the office to manage things.
And now, with working from home,
that looks a little different,
but we still want to have
people awake and available
and in their office, wherever
that may be, just in case.
Because you want to
just be online and ready
and not waking up.
No one likes to wake up in the
middle of the night for things
like this.
And similarly, when it comes
the holidays or certain events,
we find that are there
times that we would just not
want to risk an
upgrade, just to make
sure we provide the best quality
of service to our customers?
Absolutely.
Having that flexibility
has been critical for us
and will continue to be critical
for us as we continue to grow.
KOBI MAGNEZI: That's awesome.
And I think another
recommendation
that we already
kind of implicitly
mentioned several
times is having
multiple environments set up.
I can't stress enough how
important and essential
it is to have a preproduction
environment in place
so you can reliably deliver
upgrades to your infrastructure
and to your software safely
and in timely manner.
You can think about
it in a way that you
have testing
environments to test out
new releases before rolling
them out to production.
In this case, we recommend
subscribing both your testing
cluster and your production
cluster to the same channel
so you can use the same version
between testing and production.
In some cases, you
may want to consider
a canary or even
second development
environment to test out newer
releases using the Rapid
channel.
That will give
you an opportunity
to stay ahead of the curve
by testing out new Kubernetes
features or API and
basically improve your time
to market when
those versions get
promoted from Rapid to Regular,
and then finally to Stable.
With multiple
environments, we also
need an efficient way to
orchestrate and upgrade
workflow across
multiple environments.
But in order to be
proactive about it,
you need to be able to predict
when an upgrade is scheduled
for your cluster.
There's a great way to do so.
We have GKE release notes
that also offer RSS feeds.
You can use that.
Also, if you are using
release channels,
each channel offers
a separate release
note so you can only subscribe
to the updates that's
relevant to your cluster.
You can use GKE API--
specifically, Git
Server Config--
to retrieve the list
of available version.
These all options
are great, but they
do require you to pull the
information on a regular basis.
So you to be proactive about it.
So to simplify this
process even more,
we are introducing GKE
upgrade notification,
which will be beta launched
later this quarter.
Upgrade notification is
based on Cloud pub/sub.
It allows customer to subscribe
to upgrade events and get
automatically informed about
new available versions,
and also when the
upgrade actually
takes place on their cluster.
In this case that I
have here in this slide,
we have a devops steam
using a Slack channel.
And [INAUDIBLE] is being
pushed to their Slack channel
through the pub/sub
subscription.
And the team, this way, know
about and notified ahead
of time about new versions.
This way, the team
can optionally
orchestrate a specific
workflow-- for example,
upgrade their testing
environment first
to validate their
release, make sure
that their release is
ready to be safely roll out
into production environment.
So let's put
everything together.
We spoke about
different concepts.
A recommended approach to
automate and streamline
upgrades would involve
preproduction environment,
using the available version
that we mentioned before,
and upgrade notification that's
set up on your cluster that
will inform your team when
a new available version is
ready for them to
test and certify,
and eventually, a
production environment
subscribed to a release channel
using the default version
in that channel.
DONOVAN CARTER: So
we've covered a lot.
And if you can believe
it, we've actually
got more we could cover.
But we hope that you've gotten
a sense of some of the best
practices and recommendations,
both from real-world experience
as well as from Google and
Google's experience managing
GKE, to know enough to be
really, really dangerous when
it comes to running a
highly available, really
tough with strict SLOs/SLAs
product in Google Kubernetes
Engine.
There are a lot of things
on this slide that we could
talk at great length about,
but we won't, per the interest
of time.
But we also just
want to thank you
real quick for spending
your time with us
and getting to hear a
little bit about this.
And I really
appreciate Kobi's time
and getting to do
this with him, one,
because it's just fun, and
two, because it's something
that I really care about.
So thank you, Kobi, and thanks,
folks, for watching it all.
KOBI MAGNEZI: Thank
you for tuning in.